oh another gift another goodie what's
coming out of the star wars toys
we got rancors back
yes is this
it
no i don't know it's moochie it's danny
[Laughter]
i love it wow definitely rodriguez just
pulling out all of his stops to get his
buddies in this oh my god and
definitely a more fit uh rancor trainer
yeah yeah
but what is this why just these gifts
yeah there's
something backhanded about this i know
it welcome back to new rockstars the
book of boba fett episode 3 takes from
us our tuscan family but gives us in
exchange danny trejo and steven root in
a depressed rancor yeah but uh like any
odd exchange what's the catch to this
gift like why are the huts backing off
tatooine for real and uh what are those
gropey twins really planning what the
fact all i could think about was
it was a threesome with boba fett and
then like what are they really planning
uh threesome
the most round about threesome they go
back to nowhere to be like
we're trying everything i'm putting
myself out there this year we give him a
wookie we give him a ring
about that
um well this is wikileaks it's new
rockstar's book of boba fett after show
and our weekly reaction into the latest
in star wars i'm eric voss my easter egg
breakdown for episode three is coming
tomorrow but right now i am here
reacting to this episode with tommy
bechtole oh baby a short and sweet
episode of book of boba fett not uh not
not uh not uh what i would call a
lengthy thrill ride but a thrill ride
nonetheless a very sm slow moving
through ride at times uh
just gingerly moving about the streets
of moss espa but uh
we'll definitely talk about that but
like i i just have to point out to
everyone who's saying that this street
chase moved too slow like watch any
street chase whether it's in back to the
future or yeah or american graffiti or
even fast the furious the shots that are
not cgi
things are moving slower in when they're
actually shooting it absolutely you know
that seems like it is with editing
absolutely and this was it had to move
slow because they needed to show
all of those great characters all the
great cameos and stuff you couldn't do
we needed yeah
every little thing we needed you can't
just be a motion blur streak of that
droid that toted padme and anakin around
that's right you need to get a reaction
shot where he goes
out of the way
i mean i loved it he wanted to say oh my
so bad like it was like they were they
wanted an anthony daniels oh my oh my oh
all we needed was like someone to carry
a cake
well we got a looney tunes
shattering portrait we got that we did a
ralph robert mccoy
and this is the second ralph mcquarrie
reference in two weeks now because that
uh
some of our viewers were
about to point out the tentacle tree
branch scene was based on some concept
art from ralph mcquarrie so yeah we're
getting some macquarie tributes yeah
production design is amazing here well
let's break down what happened this
episode episode three because with 88 uh
matt barry anytime i hear his voice just
can't not think of jackie
daytona he breaks down essentially what
bib fortuna's operation was the three
family yeah
you got the transition so you got your
aqualicious you're gonna be sleeping
with the fishes soon and then you got
your cluttonians days
uh i just love the breakdown of that i
would have loved if we saw like you know
a good fella style like police fbi chart
there was billy two gills and then there
was jimmy three blasters who always
blasted a person three times how's your
mother how's your mother
but um
we meet this water broker lorth appeal
played by the amazing stephen f yes
uh and i call him steven f root i know
he's stephen root but because at the
university of florida where many of us
at new rockstars all went uh the acting
studio where our improv club would
always try to sneak in in front of play
rehearsals was called the stephen f
roots acting studio because he's an
alumnus of the university of florida and
he paid like a hundred thousand dollars
in donations to build out their their
nativity mcguire uh theater dance
pavilion but the the theater um i i just
i have to use my platform now to shout
out how terrible that theater department
was to us they were huge [ __ ] i will
never forgive them they canceled our
main stage show for no reason because
some of their grad students were
drinking beer at one of our shows and
they blamed us for it so [ __ ] you
university of florida yeah
circa 2008 you made my life hell then
anyway do you think every time steven
root appears on a uh
high budget prestige television show
like another petal drops from a tree in
his house and when the tree is bare
he will have done his he will have done
his service and his soul can finally be
free because he shows up on everything i
mean he i mean like at a certain point
steven root will appear on your show
whether you cast him or not like i feel
like he just go he shows up and he's
like yeah i'm north appeal and they're
like well it's stephen root so i guess
he's right he's not even on the call
sheet he's just he's just there he's
just there he's like i feel like my name
should be lorth appeal i'm gonna play a
water broker who checks on my prices too
much and we buy it it feels it feels so
simple and mundane to have this guy in
your world i love that he's so low
stakes like you're gonna get steven root
you could make him like the big bad
show that's how great this actor is
absolutely he's like no no i'm going to
play
like uh middle management just one step
above the local street gangs yes he's
getting ripped off absolutely
great great casting there um well he
he asks uh boba fett to punish these
gang and they're they're these cyborgs
they're people and i love that he says
that with like a sneer not realizing
that fenix shand is augmented with
cybernetic parts as well like it's star
wars a ton of people get cybernetic luke
skywalker's got a cybernetic hand why
are you still grossed out by that um but
uh he uh they pay him no respect and i
love how he keeps saying i'm insulted on
your behalf yeah he's like the little
jerk who goes up to he's like these
people are talking about you didn't even
do about it it's not me i didn't say
this you didn't hear it from me
did you hear this from me but yeah i
love it
says it again yeah like he's got like
one thing he can say he's like demarco
rubio in the debates he's like fennec
shan's just gonna accuse him of having
small hands next they're gonna be
yeah um well we meet this gang it
includes sophie thatcher uh she is
having a moment right now uh between
this and yellow jackets she's great um
and they ride these colorful vespa type
uh speeders yeah seem to be inspired by
the bikes driven by uh mods these are
like the whole youth gangs of london in
the 60s and they had these bright colors
i just love that kind of cultural pull
it was cool
it did remind me a little bit of the
diner scene and attack of the clothes it
was like slightly like this
this is very colorful very very colorful
but i still listen i would die to drive
one of those speeder bikes around so
it's uh it's more color than we're used
to seeing outside of big uh urban
centers like curacao like to see this
much color on on tatooine outside of
like even the pod racers are all dusty
and caked in mud and stuff these seem
like nicely polished right out of like a
toy pinball machine you know so anyway
um but boba makes the right decision
here he says he sees that this gang has
no work and that's really the problem
it's unemployment it's lack of
employment opportunities it's jobs job
jobs baby so he gives them jobs
enforcers really pissing off mortha and
says lower your prices
in a clean stroke gives people jobs and
says your prices are too different this
is uh this is boba's applaud boba's
build buildback better plan i think is
what he probably is
but it has two tiers of it right it also
does a bit of a price controlling built
back better back to
barbie
[Laughter]
boba well we get another of these
flashback does and it is haunting
because boba remembers this time when he
leaves this tuscan tribe not knowing
this will be the last we see
and uh he goes to collect the toll from
the pikes and maz eisley the [ __ ]
that he mentioned earlier in the episode
stormtrooper helmets on the on the pikes
that we saw in mandalorian episode five
and we actually get a quick cameo by amy
sedaris says felimota walking by with
her pit droids love it uh and then we
get uh we meet the pike leader who says
that he's already paying for protection
from that nicto gang and he names them
the kenton striders
okay and uh and boba will have to settle
things with them and i oh i love this
recurring thing of every person boba
fett meets with keeps like punting yeah
you have to go talk to this person
actually your princess is in another
castle
[Music]
exactly
um but upon his return bubba gets his
own uncle owen and peru moment and finds
that tuscan tribe massacred apparently
by the kenton striders but we're not you
know they just had their obvious symbol
painted there anybody could have painted
that symbol yeah i think it's probably
the content spiders but we'll see
there's a lot been a lot of deception
this season we'll talk more about that
but you know one theme has certainly
been this year of as you said passing
the buck onto someone else and saying
like it couldn't have been me it was
this person so
i think i i playing enemies against each
other yes yes um you know it was just
steven rude out there spraying like is
does the l go this way
but bobo wakes up either the best or the
worst way to wake up from any nap
screaming wookie in your face black or
satan
yes
somehow he got into this palace and he
is savage uh we see a wookie bite which
is vicious like it's just a nasty fight
uh it's awesome but boba is just like
barely clothed it's full viggo martin
saint and eastern provinces
yeah it's wet it's hot i love it yeah uh
but then uh they're able barely to
restrain this wookie everyone's pitching
in here uh but it's really just finicky
and being like wait just try to get him
right over that right over that trapdoor
almost can you take a swing on him let
him bite your face okay great great and
we got him uh nice nice little trap
there um and they are able to keep them
down there but the hutt twins then
arrive and they bring with them as a
gift a rancor
uh handled by danny trejo
and
now they're promising to lead tatooine
because they were misled by mayor mark
shays and uh and
now they're saying there's a syndicate
that has claimed uh this territory they
don't want any part of it they're afraid
and then they bounce
now uh danny trejo explains the
intricacies of the rancor personality he
name drops the witch is the dathomir
shadows of the empire
that's right and he explains how rancors
are complex emotional creatures that
imprint on the first human they see and
then so it seems like fett forms this
bond with the new rancor hopes to train
it and then uh fat and chand uh in those
cyborg guards go to masses but a
question makshi's for the mayor is
absent the major doma goes i'll be right
back
and then we get this uh super slow but
delightful paced uh
speeder chase through the streets of
moscow uh crashing into every droid and
alien costume that they have in the
warehouse at skywalker ranch but it's
wonderful yes uh and then it ends with
uh the major domo crashing biff style
into a cart of milaroon fruit which i
just love that you know i love seeing
those things bounce around i think we
saw it on a menu at the end of uh at the
end of uh mandalorian season two so now
we get to see those delicious looking
fruits uh i want all the olive oils i
want a miller and fruit
right now for breakfast well there's a
little cottage cheese in it
yeah oh that sounds great yeah but the
gang corners them he says that uh again
he punts he goes oh uh mayor cheyes is
working with the pikes you know so
everyone's just saying you gotta go over
here you gotta go over here and then one
of that's informative reports that more
pikes are arriving in to the planet and
the crime boss states that this empire
is ready for war but what kind of war is
he going to have to fight are his
numbers anywhere near does not seem that
way right now especially with his tuscan
connection seemingly yeah a little
crispy
they're not original recipe anymore they
are extra crispy unfortunately yeah
um and it just sets up some interesting
questions over well then what is uh
boba fett really fighting for then we
were thinking maybe he was trying to
claim this throne and then give the
tuscans a seat at the table has he
formed alliances with other tuscan
tribes since then uh that we don't know
about or is this really a vengeance
quest which is also very exciting
yeah especially about rage boba fett and
fenix and i i will watch them mow
through people any day you know well uh
we want to thank our merch partners at
epic hero shop they have a new shirt in
their latest obsession series inspired
by the book of boba fett comes in three
colors and i think the military green
one is most character appropriate they
look amazing definitely get your hands
on one of these and when you grab a
latest obsession shirt you'll get the
added option to write in a custom shout
out that will appear at the bottom of
these book of boba fett after shows like
we got james asking where do you think
they will go with the introduction of bk
uh yeah i i mean i ultimately think this
is going to lead to either an obi-wan
kenobi series parallel or a cameo there
or introduction to dr aphra yeah into uh
into live action i would love either one
of those um nashen asks who would win in
a fight boba fett or finnick shand who
do you think tommy
ah you know i
this is really tough because fennec
shand it seems at this point more
ruthless than boba fett boba fett's kind
of like had enough life experiences
where i think he would maybe show it uh
show mercy and fenix would take that
opportunity to uh slit his throat yeah
yeah i think so um and then justin asks
do you think boba fett killed the
sarlacc making his escape i mean i don't
know how a sarlacc would recover it
seems like his metabolism is super slow
i would imagine his healing
processes are super expensive and i
think you know the straight tentacles
kind of implied some sort of uh
medicine yeah it looks kind of limp yeah
dead yeah for sure um well check out all
of our awesome merch options in new
rockstarsmerch.com but let's dive in to
the deeper questions we have from this
episode where do we want to start tommy
you know eric i've been wondering since
i watched this episode only a few short
hours ago what the fact
are the true intentions of the hops
ah yes well the hutts surprisingly back
off of boba in this episode as soon as
bk just fails to kill him they admit to
cindy black or santa to go kill him i
mean not a bad strategy
like said yeah so send a murderous
you know teddy bear to kill boba fett a
guy who loves to take healing naps four
times a day
very little protection it turns out yeah
yeah a pretty winning strategy um but
they don't want chris santan back
they're like all right our contract is
uh done with you um
and then they they leave
this rancor with boba and they don't
really seem to be getting anything out
of this exchange which is super
uncharacteristic of the hunts and they
say they want no part of this uh
territory right now they forced their
litter to carry them back into town they
came all the way out here just to say
this you know one of those characters is
like you know we have holograms
right yeah just use the technique please
we've taught you how to use it please
we'll show you again grandma we'll set
up the call for you you have texting on
your iphone grandma grandma you just
text us you do not you know landline
those huts are like that's not going to
send a message at all like i prefer
why are we talking like
i don't know
and it's not it's not okay no we're not
okay i think it's because the waiting
talking about he's just like
yeah we should not do our pod shots try
to speed her teeth and then we offend no
one but i'm dying to know what changed
with the hutt's circumstances for
somebody acting this way i'm not sure
anything eric i don't i'm sorry to
interject but i just
i wonder if it's like one of those too
good to be true gifts you know like they
they conveniently release black
chrysanthen from his contract and then
encourage boba to keep him
like a gift they're like keep this guy
now i this is my thing with the show and
with wookies in general i have such an
attachment to chewbacca that i see a
wookie and i'm like there's no way that
they could do evil black chrysanthemum
is a murderous you know gladiator as as
boba referenced too man perhaps they
wanted a wookie on the inside eric
perhaps they wanted a wookie on the
inside oh you think um black person they
were hoping he would keep black crusade
as like his own bodyguard and then he'd
report back to them i have to say i love
black or satan's little job
away from me
it was such a it it it
it's like whatever the uh wookie version
of uncanny valley was in that moment
black chrysanton became a human
performer in a wookiee costume for me
because his running style was just dad
at a softball game
it was like all right
it reminds me of like my favorite gag
from the first couple episodes of parks
and rec where at one point they just
have aziz run away
he avoids canvassing yeah they just stay
on disease running down the sidewalk and
they just go he runs weird yeah
yeah absolutely which i always found
about black i said he doesn't run that
weird it's just fun to see somebody with
big furry costumes
it just definitely was like a dad jock
it was definitely like
yeah
uh but he good on him for like he
wouldn't just walk away either he'd be
like okay i'm getting the f yeah that's
true yeah
before he changes his mind
yeah well uh tommy you were saying that
there there is some good reason for the
hutts to fear the syndicate we saw in
clone wars how you know they the
syndicate has previously attacked
jabba's palace and forced both jabba and
gorgon the hutt to join the shadow
collective the hutts though aren't
exactly safe on their home planet now
huda because the pike syndicate has a
fleet of star cruisers and we saw the
end of the episode you know and they had
previously attacked gardula the hutt on
huda and forced all the huts to flee the
planet we saw that in rebels
so
i think the i believe that the pike
syndicate um might be more powerful at
least have more of a reach than the
hutt's clan right now now that uh jabba
is dead um and that puts the surviving
hutt family members in a more vulnerable
position against the pike's growing
influence but what do the hutts have
more than anything than their ability
for treachery and deceit yes uh their
ability to play their enemies against
each other they're very clever these
huts they were able to stay silently
behind a curtain
when leia thought out uh han solo from
like there was a whole group of them and
java was able to be like
i want to surprise him
surprise
[Laughter]
how do you do that if you're his biggest
job how do you stay so silent with your
brain is how you do it right uh i think
obviously what is going on here is the
huts are staying out of this but really
to set up boba fett in the pikes against
each other so that they can reap the
benefits that's right
it's all about the curtains baby and i
keep saying baby this episode it's not
natural it works for me baby let me tell
you what it's natural for me i wanted to
keep going
right back
well uh
finnick and boba even say in this
episode that vets have a reputation for
playing their enemies against each other
i totally think that's happening here
but i want to ask you about this rancor
time
it's a crazy gift to give to boba
without getting anything in return
i can't help but wonder if this is a
kind of trojan horse i can't help but
look the rancor in the mouth yeah but
and danny trejo uh is playing his rancor
handler i love how he builds on uh the
lore of the rancor yes talking about
emotional complexity complexity talks
and then uh it definitely builds on that
little moment that i love from return of
the jedi alec haley sobbed when luke
killed potatoes that's right and we all
kind of laugh at that without any
context where like as a kid i was like
why is this like big shirtless bald man
crying like crying like crying like a
child over it now it's like you know it
makes so much more sense he understands
what was lost there was a sweetness in
that creature he was trained to fight
unfortunately but with other people he
had this nice relationship and i love
that danny trejo name drops the witches
of dathomir which uh is originally part
of like legend stories they're the group
of the four switches um and they were
kind of reframed as what we saw as the
night sisters in clone wars that
included towson that was maul's mother
uh that cult was critical to maul's
restoration but i love that trejo uses
the old eu term witches of dathomir
because it just kind of hints at a
deeper complexity than what we saw in
clone wars nothing wrong with clone wars
but there is like a deeper history uh to
this group and now it is official canon
and star wars which is awesome right
and there's more to rancor psychology
than we think like in that in those
legends stories as was told to luke
skywalker in those stories there was a
jedi knight alia who was the grandmother
of this group when she was outcasted
from the planet and in her tradition uh
these group of women generation after
generation uh kind of wrangle the
rancors down from the mountains and then
domesticate them but through this
process um and we learned of this
process called rancor imprinting
which is why this rancor has to wear
these blinders uh that they will
actually be loyal to the first person
they see
um now i don't mean to question this
beautiful history to the rancor species
but i have to ask you tommy could this
really be the case as we saw it could
have been a lie from trejo's character
that rancours might actually imprint a
lifelong hatred on the first person they
see so really the wrangler opens their
eyes to some mortal enemy of theirs yeah
and then it imprints them with a desire
to tear that one person to shreds and
can never be erased and that's why trejo
smiles because can we ever trust a smile
from danny trejo am i overthinking this
i'll be honest because you know uh he's
a fabulous actor and he's great at
playing
deceitful evil characters as well as
heroic violent characters but
uh you know one thing that bumped me in
this very similar way was that boba fett
leaves and it's just danny trejo in the
rancor and he just kind of gives him a
pat on the head and says he'll be back
you know like the way a dog is upset
when it's uh you know uh human friend i
almost said owner but i don't think
that's acceptable dog language anymore
person friend human keeper i don't know
you buy pay for it listen if i have kids
i'm gonna say i own them uh delete that
don't put that don't put that in there
uh
the editor's like no we're leaving it in
you [ __ ] monster uh no so anyway what
was i saying yes he
he says he'll be okay no
i think that
one that could be doubling down on danny
trejo's originals comment that
that rancors are docile unless they're
threatened they're peaceful and less
threatened he says that so
i don't know i mean it seems too much
too good to be true the trojan horse
thing makes way more sense to me that
danny trejo a it's an actor of that you
know renowned in that role
might be up to more than what he's
saying maybe the rancor stuff is all
legit but danny trejo's character is not
you know what i mean maybe he is
much like jon snow and the knights uh
joining the wildlings like fight with
them love them eat with them or whatever
it's like maybe he's been uh he's been
instructed by the the huts to train this
rancor for boba and then also get as
much information as you can so i i think
there is something to that i also
thought it was interesting
you know me and i love my bootleg
breakdowns all two of them the smash
hits on this site but
did boba fett make a reference to the
holiday special when he said he had
written larger creatures than that is
that that like dinosaur yeah thing that
he's riding because yeah the huge
creature he rides and the animated uh
because danny
had a similar kind of like thing
like like gun thing that boba fett had
in that
animation special so i i and that
brought a smile to my face that there
was a little i mean we know that
fellaini and this whole crew loves the
star wars holiday special in the first
episode of the mandalorian they
mentioned life day yes they mentioned
references
we're saying life day again we told you
that last week we said that
no we yeah no i want to say this are we
does this mean we're not far away from a
wookiee masturbation virtual reality
machine then
that might have just been specific to
the star wars yeah
and and to my house where i have spent
all of my money not what that was for
tommy that's just what you use it that's
just a fedex box i put over my
dancers that you watch oh right just
enjoyed you applause yes you're right
you're right
no no you made it weird you made it
weird um yeah i'm probably overthinking
how um how vicious and hostile this
rancor is i i think when we're peering
into its eyes i don't i just don't know
what to make of that there obviously is
a connection form there is an imprinting
process happening there um i'm just
curious to know what exactly the hutt's
intentions were and i and i think that
there still is a loyalty between trejo
and the hutts and i think that
eventually will be uh used as a way to
exploit bobo ultimately yeah i don't
think this is just a pure honest
trustworthy gift from girls at the end
of the day i agree um
well we'll talk more about what's going
on this episode in a second but uh first
we want to thank our friends at magic
spoon for sponsoring this episode we all
love delicious sweet treats but if
you're trying to look as good shirtless
as boba after the back to tank we know
we shouldn't be indulging too often and
that's where our friends at magic spoon
come in magic spoon cereal has zero
grams of sugar 13 to 14 grams of protein
and only four net grams of carbs in each
serving that's only 140 calories a
serving it's keto friendly gluten free
grain free soy free and low carb grab
yourself a variety pack for the four
flavors of cocoa fruity frosted and
peanut butter try mixing flavors to be a
real maniac magic spooner
chocolate peanut butter for a peanut
butter cup vibe or frosted and fruity
for a candy coated winter wonderland
just go to magicspoon.com wikileaks to
grab a variety pack and try today and be
sure to use our promo code wikileaks to
check out to save five dollars off your
order and magic spoon is so confident in
their product it's backed with a 100
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it for any reason they'll refund your
money no questions asked remember get
your next delicious meal of guilt-free
cereal at magicspoon.com wikileaks and
use the code wookie leaks to save five
dollars off and we thank magic spoon for
sponsoring this episode we also want to
thank our friends at peloton for
sponsoring this episode we're lucky to
have new book of boba fett episodes to
react to every week you don't want to
get burned out doing the same thing
every week every day that's true for
exercise too and it's why our friends at
peloton are always adding things to
their lineup to keep you motivated and
excited for your workout you know
peloton from their really cool bikes and
fitness equipment but they also have a
great app that everybody can use even
without the equipment they've added a
ton of workout variety to that app with
yoga dance cardio meditation and all
kinds of other classes that you can take
advantage of from the comfort of your
own home and they've just added boxing
classes which are a great workout
whether you're a seasoned pugilist or
more of a glass jaw joe i'm definitely
in that second category i could use some
of the work on fundamentals and form
that the app classes offer for a limited
time try the peloton app for free for
two months and then 12.99 per month
after that new members only visit
onepeloton.com
app to learn more that's two months free
at o n e p e l o t o n dot com offer
expires january first 1st 2022 terms
apply
all right tommy i wanted to ask you what
the bet really happened to those tuscans
could any of them have survived i got i
hope so i you know obviously the the
little
gaffy sticks our staff
little baby staff going in doesn't seem
good for the tiny
tiny tiny tiny tuscan tiny tuscans
uh
coming to tlc it's tiny tuscans uh
i just picture like dance moms but it's
tuscan raiders yeah uh no you know
you're not going to states your mouth
off one more time you're not going to
states uh
so no i think you know for that uh
badass john wick joan wick uh female
fighting uh uh tuscan raider i think
there would have had to have been like
50 kitten striders to take her out you
know like so in my mind in my hopes and
my
heart of hearts i hope that she escaped
with the young ling uh tuscans and maybe
a few of the other ones but it does
appear as though they killed the men not
just the men eric but the women and
children too
the children yeah
i mean it's it's horrible what happened
to them uh and i think what's what's
disheartening even though we don't see
the bodies of uh the warrior that helped
them out on the train or that kid
yeah their sticks are pretty sacred to
them i don't know if especially the
warrior who trained him would ever part
ways with with that scene yeah
i hope they survive i hope some of them
survived
in some way um i it just sucks for them
to i i didn't want to see the massacre
on screen but we've gotten such a
relationship and an attack yeah
yeah all kidding aside it was yeah it
was tough to like have you know get so
much of them in the first two
episodes and then be like well now
they're gone forever so
yeah i mean and not even it's just kind
of like something we move on pretty
quickly from like a third of the way
through the episode you know it'd be one
thing if like you end an episode with
this yeah and you're just left with that
into the credits
um
like like and and it's a flashback you
don't need to flashback in the middle of
the episode you could flash back at the
end of the episode and just so i don't i
i just kind of question whether this is
truly the end of uh any tuscan on the
show i hope it's not because i really
have come to love the the tuscan culture
and i don't want boba fett to be the
only bearer of any tuscan traditions now
on the show um because he is just
someone who was taught it and i i want
to see more tusks i don't want them to
just be completely massacred i agree on
uh but we know there are you know
thousands if not millions of tuscans
wandering around on this planet
hopefully two of them are ones that we
got to know already um
but who do we think it was just the
kitten striders who killed them am i
overthinking no someone else no i i 100
think especially because they keep
focusing on that logo they keep focusing
on that tag that is their like you know
uh
it heart gets back to the old wcw monday
nitro days when the nwo would spray
paint nwo on people and every once in a
while someone would frame the nwo by
spray painting nwo on a victim
and and it would really be you know like
ric flair or somebody like that so
so i i i i you know i think that no i
think it they're being set up as patsies
for this you know i think the kids and
striders are being set up as the the
people that you know they want you to
think when in reality
it's probably someone far more nefarious
it's just the pikes themselves yeah i
think so like that makes sense because
the pikes would have had knowledge or at
least an inkling that bo the boat was
coming to see them you know so like i
don't know how fast that
they they could get out there or if they
have people on the ready but like it
stands to reason they knew they had that
without their best fighter where second
best fighter boba fett you know he's
doing he's coming there to collect the
protection fee so it's the perfect time
to
go in and attack because they probably
have spies of their own you know a
scouts that are up there looking so i
think it 100 was the pikes that that's
that that makes the most sense to me i
think just that little detail of of that
one pike leader swirling his dream i
believe phil lamar played him which i
love how they get like these these
actors in here uh that we've seen
another stuff phil lamar of course
voiced uh uh bill organam and a bunch of
other characters in star wars animated
series but like yeah i think i think
there's something going on there for
sure i don't think we're we have to
assume immediately this has to have just
been the kenton striders acting alone
yeah although they're [ __ ] i
wouldn't put it past them i don't know
if they're war criminals though they
didn't they didn't kill that moisture
farmer but you know i can imagine them
having a lesser regard for tuscan
raiders than they do yes for humans okay
i want to ask you what the fed happens
to black cursantin now after his jog out
he's still jogging
he's just
marathoning through i don't think he's
done on this show even if he does even
if he does appear in other if he's
jogging straight out to ahsoka tano or
if he's jogging straight out to appear
on obi-wan because obi-wan is taking
place in a different time period anyway
right so
he could be on both anyhow i think that
he's going to regroup he's going to go
you know
blow off some steam
digest all of the gomorian flesh that he
has in his stomach from biting and uh
all of that and then i could see him
coming back and helping boba fett i
could see him coming back that's what
i'm kind of expecting i'm expecting to
kind of team up like that was another
good move of boba to create a potential
allies
yeah because it would have made way more
sense to just keep him down in the
rancor pit and give that little sweet
baby some training
meals you know like right training
wheels and training meals
like whatever he paid you i'll pay you
double you know like make a friend out
of it yeah exactly now i wanted to ask
as we wrap up right here what effect
should we really make of this which is
of dathomir reference from danny trejo's
character are we ever gonna meet the
witches of dathomir in live action are
we going to meet another character who
could be a daughter of dathomir yeah i i
think that's probably it i think i think
that nothing like that is said by
mistake or flippantly you know i mean of
course it's fun to reference and like
you know it's cool because
when things became
uh legend and non-canon for star wars
you know a lot of a lot of fans were
like i've invested so much in these like
side characters and and extended you
know universe things so i i think that
it is probably setting up for like a
badass descendant of the witches of
death for me to come in and and uh i'm
thinking you're on this show i'm
thinking the acolyte i think that could
be with the acolyte oh yeah
part of the which is a dathomir cold i
believe the accolade it's going to be
set before the the prequels oh that's
brilliant yes and i think that would be
a perfect uh setting or a perfect place
for the acolyte to take place and either
as a member of that cult in particular
or someone who's like uh fighting
against them or has escaped from that
cult or whatever it is i just hope we
see more of the witches of death me too
i i don't think really really cool
i mean there was a close-up on his face
as he said the line like i don't think
it was that line was not meant to be you
know thrown away that line was meant to
establish well i think we covered a lot
of ground in this episode had a lot of
laughs oh yeah did a lot of bits yeah
dug into a lot of theory yeah set
ourselves up to be proven wrong next
week yeah yeah let us know in the
comments when we got it wrong and i
always love a good tweet telling me
you're gonna do it no matter what in
fact you probably wouldn't have even
watched this episode you just saw the
thumbnail of it you reacted to it on
twitter or in the comments and you
didn't watch a second of it but hey
you're young you're
a certain age of fan and the world
probably isn't great for you so if it
makes you feel good to do that i don't
mind yeah okay let me be your dartboard
hurl your insults at me i can take it
look at this chest
and twins all right we'll end there
well that's gotta be it for this episode
of wikileaks again my easter egg
breakdown is coming tomorrow and tommy
and i will be back next wednesday with
our reaction chapter four of the book of
boba fett so don't forget to check out
our many great merch options at new
rockstarsmerch.com follow me at eavos
follow tommy tommy beck told follow new
rockstar subscribe to wikileaks wherever
you get your podcast thank you for
watching and we have spoken
i don't know why i did this i like that
it's not there are worries i just do
like clicks that's fine i think it was
good
you